[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome back.
In the last episode,
Kevin from GreenMobility
told us about
immutable deployments.
So do immutable
deployments apply
to other components
of your system
as well besides
Cloud Run, Kevin?
KEVIN: Yeah, we want
to run jobs everywhere
in our production environment.
And for example, you
can get into trouble
with your cron jobs.
Developers might add
or modify your jobs
in the cloud schedule,
and after a few weeks,
you're not sure what jobs are
there and what they're for.
SPEAKER: Ah.
How do you prevent that drift
for Cloud Scheduler jobs?
KEVIN: Let me show you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're using Terraform to
deploy Cloud Scheduler jobs.
And that way, all
job definitions
are in a Terraform manifest
file that's in source control.
It's easy to see when a
job was added and why.
Whenever we apply a
Terraform manifest,
Terraform compares the list of
scheduled jobs in the manifest
with the jobs in production.
It then adds all the list of
jobs in production as needed
to make sure that production
contains only the jobs listed
in the manifest.
SPEAKER: Nice.
That ensures that the production
environment stays consistent.
What else are you doing to
keep production under control?
KEVIN: We are also
focusing on security.
We needed to provide
transparency and be
strict about who can see what.
For example, access groups--
we have a BI and data.
They can run reports.
We have a DevOps group.
They can deploy code
and view production.
And then, we have a dev group.
That can't view production,
but they can check in code.
SPEAKER: Ah, but Kevin, if your
developers don't have access
to the production
environment, how
do they know what settings
and code would work there?
KEVIN: We have
many dev projects.
Developers are free to
experiment with settings
and test their code
in those projects.
And every now and then,
we destroy the dev
projects and create new
ones using the settings
in our production project.
SPEAKER: Ah.
As you went full
serverless, is there
anything that worked
differently than you expected?
KEVIN: Yeah, the
Cloud Scheduler.
For example, it
wouldn't start new jobs
if old ones were running.
So our solution
to get around that
was just using two
Cloud Schedulers.
It's actually cool, because it
means that the scheduler keeps
track of what is
running, which can
prevent some really bad bugs.
For example, if two
instances of the same job
are trying to modify the
database at the same time,
for example, you could get
into really serious trouble.
SPEAKER: Mm, that makes sense.
KEVIN: Also, we find that many
of our jobs run at five minutes
past the hour, every hour.
That puts a lot load on
our cloud SQL database.
We could manually schedule the
job start times over the hour,
but we have a lot of scheduled
jobs, and we keep adding more.
It would be nice if Cloud
Scheduler could just
run our jobs randomly for us.
SPEAKER: I will let
the project manager
for Cloud Scheduler know.
Is there anything
else you've done
to be more productive
with Google Cloud?
KEVIN: Some tasks
I perform often,
like switching between
projects and users,
requires a lot of clicking and
waiting in the Cloud Console.
I wrote two command-line tools,
dpc-run and dpc-auth-user,
to quickly navigate
between projects and users.
They were easy to
write, as you can
do so much with the [INAUDIBLE]
commands from a shell script.
Feel free to use it.
SPEAKER: Nice, I
will check them out,
and I will put the link
in the description below.
Any other learnings, Kevin?
KEVIN: We also need to
sync tens of thousands
of records between our system
and an external system,
and this happens a
few times per hour.
At first, we had
a system dedicated
to running this, which
was slow and complicated.
So what we did was
we split this big job
into 500 small jobs
using Cloud Tasks, which
meant we could run them
asynchronously in parallel.
We found the Cloud Tasks made
it easy to kick off these 500
jobs quickly, and
also, the code that
ran each of these 500
small jobs became simpler.
SPEAKER: 500 jobs?
Does it that make it
harder to handle errors?
KEVIN: It actually
makes it easier.
Each job is shorter, so
fewer things can go wrong.
And if any of the
500 jobs fails,
Cloud Tasks tries it again.
We don't have to write any
of the retry logic ourselves.
SPEAKER: Oh, nice.
So Kevin, what's the verdict?
Does serverless get a thumbs
up or a thumbs down from you?
KEVIN: A big thumbs up.
I could have built the data
just in backends, scheduled jobs
and so on using
virtual machines,
but our team has saved so much
time by doing it serverlessly
with Firestore Cloud Run,
BigQuery Cloud Task, and also
Cloud Scheduler.
It means that we
have been able to add
more functionality to our
cloud sharing platform quicker.
SPEAKER: Good to hear, Kevin.
Thanks for sharing
your serverless
experiences, and thank you,
everyone, for watching.
If you have questions
for Kevin or me,
please add them in the comments.
Also, this episode was a little
different from the others
in the Serverless
Expedition Series.
Please let us know if
you found it useful,
and be sure to like this video
and subscribe to the channel.
Until next time!
[MUSIC PLAYING]